In this video,
we'll describe a very important
problem in natural language processing.
The problem of language model.
So a language model is a
probabilistic model that is signs,
probabilities to any sequence of words.
So it's a distribution essentially
on a sequences of words,
on sentences and documents.
And so the problem of language modeling
or the task of language modeling is to
actually learn such a model that will
assign high probabilities to a well formed
sentences.
So sentences that are likely to be written
in some document or heard or and so
on.
Um,
this is a problem or task that is very
important. Natural language processing.
A lot of systems actually incorporate
in language modeling component such as
speech recognition systems and
machine translation systems.
So find stance,
uh,
if we add a sentence wanted to
translate in Beth [inaudible] and uh,
we had assistant that's pretty good at
just translating each individual words.
So in would be the Sim would know
that you would translate it to uh,
which is here also.
And Besson would be translated by person.
And then I tell you, Shannon
would be considered by smart. Um,
but imagine our system is also not so
good at determining the order of these
words, then, uh, in, in the setting, uh,
language model would be very useful in
distinguishes funds funds since whether
we should prefer a person smart or a
smart person as a good translation of in
fascinated Asia and particular if you
have a good language model than it would
recognize that this has a
higher probability of being
a written by a person in
English,
then a person smart.
So in this case it would have been
able to reorder Besson and put it after
antigen out in, in the actual
translation in English. So,
um, there are many other types of
usage of uh, language modeling, uh,
and language problems, uh, sorry, language
models. Uh, and so they are really,
really important in natural
language processing.
Okay.
And the assumption that
one often makes when, uh,
someone designs a language model is to
make the nef order Markov assumption.
What this assumption,
uh,
says is that if we have a distribution
of probability distribution over a
sequence, then, uh, the, uh, uh,
then we're assuming that we can write
it as the product of the probability of
each element of the sequence given only
the n minus one previous elements in
that sequence.
Or in our case we're modeling words.
So we're assuming that the
word at position t is only
dependent on the n minus
one previous words and does not
depend on the other words, uh,
before that in the sequence of words
in this sentence or in the document.
Um, so this is, uh,
restrictive, uh, assumption. Uh,
it essentially never,
he holds it really holds I,
except for perhaps very, very
large and values. And, um,
and whenever I'm going
to talk about context,
I'm going to talk about these
n minus one people's words.
They're the words on which
were conditioning the
probability of observing the
next word.
So,
uh,
the,
a model which or type of model that is
very frequently used in natural language
processing is known as the engram model.
So first,
let's describe what we mean by Anne Graham
and then drive is just a sequence of
and words that, uh, usually we extract
from some training data from some,
uh, uh, corpus of words. So for instance,
it would just take that sentence
here as our corpus, our,
our training data. Uh, then, uh,
the unigrams that are
contained is what there is, is,
which is right here.
There's a,
there's a sequence and all of the
other individual words in that, uh,
in that sentence,
uh,
examples of backgrounds taken from
that sentence would be as, uh,
because we have is
followed by, uh, here, uh,
also a sequence because we have, uh,
followed by sequence here and so on.
And then try grounds,
which corresponds to an equals three.
And then Graham for any equals
three, uh, when an example is,
is a sequence because we have is a
sequence here, uh, as sequence of,
because we have a sequence
of here and so on.
So that's what an then Graham is really
just a sequence of and words that is
usually extract them from some,
from Beta, remove some ink.
And so,
um,
and then Graham model is going to estimate
the conditional probability that we
need in our mark of model for assigning
the probability of a whole document or
sentence a is going to estimate that
conditional probability based on counts of
and grams that counts that are extracted
from some training corpus of training
data.
Uh,
so specifically if we had a set of words,
the m minus one people's words or the
context and we're monitoring what's the
probability of some given
word that is observed next.
But what we do is that we would count.
So imagine we have dysfunction count that
just contains the number of times that
the context,
so the word from position t minus one t
minus and minus one up to t a w WT minus
one.
So the number of times we've observed
this context followed this word wt.
The probability conditional
probably as a modeled by, uh,
estimated by this model is going
to be proportional to that count.
And then we're going to normalize that
by the number of times we've seen this
context followed by any word.
So by dividing this way,
then we're guaranteed that this
estimate of the probability is about it.
Probability it's going to sum to one.
Yeah.
No [inaudible] models have one particular
problem or challenge that I have to
face.
Uh,
and it's a problem data sparsity so if
you want a good model that's accurate,
that that is close to reality,
a really what we want is,
and to be as large as possible.
Otherwise,
once it's for any equals one,
then we actually assuming that all the
words are independent because then the n
minus one previous words, that's one
minus one. That's the zero previous words.
So we conditioning on no words
before, uh, any word for,
uh,
when we're modeling the probability
of each word in the sentence.
So effectively we're considering
that all the words are independent,
the seeds sequence, which is
of course a very crude, uh,
assumption to make a,
if that any calls to them,
we're just assuming that
if we know one word,
then the distribution of
the next word is, uh, uh,
not influenced by the third word before
or fourth word before then. So on.
Uh, uh, so, uh, so that again is a very
crude approximation. So really we want,
and to be as large as possible
to get a realistic model,
Howard for large values of n,
then it means that when we're estimating
these probabilities in this end grand
model, uh, it's going to be
much more likely that for
some new data and some, uh,
testing corporate for which we are
evaluating the probability of sentences,
it's going to be much more likely that
we will have never seen the exact context
for which we have to
condition for evaluating our
conditional probabilities in
the uh, and grand model. And so, uh,
there are ways of
alleviating this problem. Uh,
essentially they're all variants of this
idea of smoothing the accounts that is,
uh, when we're, for instance,
estimating the probability of some
word given the three previous words.
So we have, uh, uh, for gram here model.
And then instead of just making that
proportional to the number of times we've
seen w one followed by w
two w two and NW for a,
and then normalizing,
we actually have this
probability be proportional
to a combination of the counts
of seeing w one up next
to w two w three and four.
And then combined with the number of
times we've seen just w two followed by w
three w four. And then combine
that also with w three and four.
And then the number of
times we've seen w four.
And so there's a whole literature on ways
of combining these different counts to
get a, a model that doesn't ever
fit as much in generalizes better.
Uh, but, uh, actually
as we'll see, uh, uh,
this only partly solves the problem in
the sense that there's something better
we can do a,
and specifically we'll see a neural
network language model that they cannot
perform this approach.